je sais pas encore ce que c'est moi même
bien que ces vaches de bourgeois ya
certes de besoin l'étape fait des filles
de joie les aspects des filles de joie
c'est pas tous les jours que rigole
paroles paroles c'est pas tous les jours
que rigole le car même avec des pieds de
grue car même avec des pieds de grue
fait les cent pas le long des rues faire
les cent pas le long des rues c'est
fatigant pour les guiboles paroles
paroles
c'est fatigant pour les guiboles non
seulement pervan les corps non seulement
fait long les corps des seuils de belles
rimes est encore d oeil de perdrix mais
encore c'est fou c'est qu'elle use and
roll paroles paroles c'est tout ce que
tu veux
or il ya des clients ya des [ __ ] ya
des clients il ya des [ __ ] qui se
trompe jamais dans l'eau qui ce temps
peut jamais dans l'eau popo temps
qu'elle les cajole
paroles paroles faut pourtant qu'elle
les cachots qu'elle la fasse la courte
échelle qu'elle en fasse la courte
échelle pour monter au septième ciel
pour monter au septième ciel l'esu
croyait pas qu'elle ait vol paroles
paroles l'esu croyait pas quel rôle
elles sont méprisées du public
elles sont méprisées du public elles
sont bousculés par les flics
elles sont bousculés par les flics et
menacé de lavéra paroles paroles et
menacé de l'aveyron vient toute la ville
fasse l'amour vient toute la ville fasse
l'amour qu'elles se marient 20 fois par
jour qu'elle se marie 20 fois par jour
l'annoncé jamais pour la fiente paroles
paroles
là ne sait jamais pour le viol de fils
de p corps et de minus fils de p corps
et de minutie pas de la pauvre venus
ripa de la pauvre venus
la pauvre vieille casserole paroles
paroles la pauvre vieille casserole
il s'en fallait de peu mon cher il s'en
fallait de peu mon cher que cette [ __ ]
de fut amère que cette [ __ ] le fut
amère cette [ __ ] avant tu rigoles
paroles paroles
cette [ __ ] long du rigaux